[Music]
they're both adults
maybe Brandon more so sorry Pamela
Anderson opening up to et about the
physical altercation between her 22 year
old son Brandon and his dad
Pam's x-com Ely they patched it up
I don it's between them the incident
went down a march at the Motley Crue
rockers Los Angeles area home and led to
a criminal investigation there were no
charges filed both Brandon and Pamela
cited alcoholism as the source of the
drama a claim
Tommy denied I wish the best of
everybody but you know rock we're all
growing and learning and as this is part
of it it's so result and you know life
goes on Tommy and Pamela also share a 20
year old son Dylan together and while
promoting her new book lust for love the
model talked about raising two boys you
love your family so how do you keep that
all together and still like keep your
family the best reward is to really see
your kids grow up to see them grow up so
healthy and my kids are ambitious they
know what they want they think they're
good at things they're talented they're
they're so creative and they're just
living this colorful life what are you
teaching your boys about respecting
women and how to love in a relationship
and really love it's just been the three
of us you know they've had
the Shawnee and Santa I've given them
for a men but I wanted my boys to be
able to feel safe be who you are
chivalry chivalry romantic I'm take
chances be brave stay committed in
relationship don't fall for these things
that everybody else is doing be a
pioneer and so I've always raised them
to be themselves and to trust their
instincts and not to be like everybody
else
[Music]
[Applause]